[Music]  look at yourself  jordan sick you're a  sick man [ __ ] you i told you you're not  taking my [ __ ] kids a [ __ ] you think  i would let my kids  near you look at yourself you know what  my lawyer said  my lawyer said that you've gone to  prison for 20 years jordan  20 [ __ ] years you're never going to  see the kids again you don't think i'm  going to see myself no i'm not [ __ ]  letting you near my kids  i'm going to see my [ __ ] kids again  huh don't you [ __ ] touch them  don't you  to god i will [ __ ] kill you  all right baby daddy i'm gonna go a  little trip together okay  little trip together  i'm taking him with me i told you i'm  taking her with me you [ __ ] [ __ ]  you're not gonna stop me you're not  gonna stop me  [Music]  get the hell out of here  all right  defendant shall plead guilty to all  counts of the indictment currently  pending against him in the united states  district court for the eastern district  of new york  you